ANDREW SELLE: So today I'm going
to talk about TensorFlow Lite,
and I'll give you an
intro to what that is.
My name's Andrew Selle.
I'm a software engineer down in
Google in Mountain View land.
All right, so introduction.
We're going to be talking about
machine learning on-device.
So how many of you are
interested on running
your machine learning
models on-device?
How many already do that?
OK, so a lot.
So that's great.
So you already know that
machine learning on-device
is important.
So I'm going to give
you a scenario that's
perhaps a little bit
out of the ordinary.
Suppose I'm going camping.
I don't have any power.
I don't have any
network connectivity.
I'm out in the mountains.
And I want to detect bears.
So I want to hang my cell
phone on the outside of my tent
so that if I'm in the
middle of the night
and the bear is coming
for me, I'll know.
I don't know what to
do if that happens,
but that's a great example of
what you do with on-device ML.
So you basically want
to have low latency.
You don't want to wait for the
bear to already be upon you.
You want some early warning.
You want to make sure it works
without a data connection.
The data can stay on the
device and you have access
to the sensors.
So there's a lot more kind of
practical and important use
cases than that.
But that kind of sets
the stage for it.
And so people are, of course,
doing a lot more ML on-device.
So that's why we
started TensorFlow Lite.
So in short, TensorFlow
Lite is our solution
for running on-device
machine learning
with low latency and
a small binary size
but on many platforms.
So here's an example of
what TensorFlow Lite can do.
So let's play our video.
So, suppose we
have these objects
and we want to recognize them.
Well, I know what they
are, but I want my phone
to be able to do that.
So we use an image
classification model.
So here we have a marker.
In the bottom you see
kind of the confidence.
So this is an image recognition.
It's happening in real time.
It can do kind of
ordinary office objects,
but also important objects
like TensorFlow logos.
And it also runs on
multiple platforms.
So here we have it running on an
Android phone and an IOS phone.
But we're not just
limited to phones.
We can also do things like
this Android Things Toolkit.
And there is going to be
a couple more later, which
I'll show you some more.
So now that we've
seen it in action,
let's talk a little bit more
about what TensorFlow Lite is.
Do you want to see
the video again?
I don't know.
OK, there we go.
The unfortunate
thing about on-device
though is it's much harder.
It has tight memory constraints,
you need to be low energy,
and you don't have as much
computation as you do available
on the cloud.
So TensorFlow Lite
has a few properties
that are going to sort of
deal with these problems.
So the first one is it
needs to be portable.
You know, normal PCs
we run on, but we also
run on mobile phones, we run
on Raspberry Pi, or other Linux
SOCs, IoT type devices.
And we also want to go
to much smaller devices
like microcontrollers.
So, next slide.
The internet doesn't
like me today.
Well, we'll skip that
slide, whatever that was.
But in any case,
basically, this portability
is achieved through the
TensorFlow Lite file format.
So once you have a trained
TensorFlow model, like you
author, you could
author it with Swift,
you could author it with
Python, whatever you do,
you produce a saved
model in a graph form.
The serialized form is then
converted to TensorFlow Lite
format, which then is your
gateway to running on all
these different platforms.
And we have one more
special converter
which allows you
to go to Core ML
if you want to target IOS
in this especially way.
The second property is
that it's optimizable.
We have model compression,
we have quantization,
we have CPU kernel fusion.
These are all
optimization techniques
to ensure that we have the
best performance, as well
as a small size.
And this is achieved
through the architecture.
So we have a converter, which
we already talked about,
and then we have an
interpreter core.
The interpreter core
delegates to kernels
that know how to do things,
just like in TensorFlow.
But unlike in
TensorFlow these are
optimized for mobile and small
devices with NEON on ARM.
An additional thing that
we have that TensorFlow
doesn't have is the
notion of delegation.
So we can delegate to GPUs
or Edge TPUs or accelerators.
And this basically
gives TensorFlow Lite
the chance to give
part of the graph
to a hardware accelerator
that can do processing
in a special way.
So one of those we've talked
about before is in an API.
We're excited to
announce that in 2018 Q4
we're looking to release
our OpenGL-based GPU
delegate, which will give us
better performance on GPUs,
and will also accelerate
things like MobileNet
and another vision-based models.
So that's really exciting.
In addition, at Cloud Next
there was an announcement
about Edge TPUs.
And Edge TPUs are
also special as well
because they give
us the ability to do
high performance
per watt, and also
fit into a small footprint.
So for example, the device
is there on that penny there,
but it's on a development board.
So you can put it in many
different form factors as well.
Then the third property is
that it's parametrically sized.
So we know the
TensorFlow Lite needs
to fit on small devices,
especially very small devices
like MCUs, And there, you
might need to only include
the ops that you need.
So our base interpreter
is about 80 kilobytes,
and with all built-in
ops it's 750 kilobytes.
We're moving to a world
where you can parameterize
what you put into the
TensorFlow Lite interpreter,
so you can trade off
the ability to handle
new models that use new ops, and
the ability to only ship what
you need in your application.
So, we introduced
TensorFlow Lite last year
and we've been asking users what
they think of TensorFlow Lite.
And they really love the
cross platform deployment
that they can deploy
to IOS, to Android
with the same kind of format.
They like that they can decouple
the distribution of the binary
from the distribution
of the model.
And they like the
inference speed increases.
And they're really excited
about the hardware acceleration
roadmap.
But the biggest
feedback that we got
is that we should focus on ease
of use, we should add more ops,
and we should work on
model optimization,
and we should provide
more documentation.
And so we've listened.
So what I want to
do in this talk
is focus on the user experience.
But before we do
that, let's look
at some of the users that
are already using it so far.
We have a lot of
first party users
and a lot of third party users
that are excited about it.
And I hope after this talk
you'll be interested as well.
So, the user's experience.
I'm a new user and I want
to use TensorFlow Lite.
How do I do it?
Well, I think of it as kind
of like learning to swim.
You can think of two
things you might do.
You might wade, where you
don't really have to swim.
But it's really
easy to get started
and you get to cool off.
The second thing is
that you can swim
where you can do custom models.
So we're going to talk
about both of those.
But before we get
into that, there's
an easier thing and
then a harder thing.
So the easier thing is to dip
your toes, which are demos.
And the harder thing
is to just dive full in
and have full kind of
mastery of the whole water,
and that would be
optimizing models.
And we'll talk
about those as well.
So as far as using demo apps,
you can go to our website,
you can download the demos
and compile it and run it.
It'll give you a flavor
of what can be done.
I showed you one
of those demo apps.
You can try it for yourself.
The next step is to use
a pre trained model.
So the demo app uses
So you can use that model
in your application.
So if you have something that
could benefit from say ImageNet
style classification, you
can just take that model
and include it.
Another thing that's really
useful is retraining.
So let me show you a
retraining workflow, which
is you take a pre trained model
and you kind of customize it.
Great, so we're
running this video.
We're showing you the
scissors and the Post-It Notes
as before, and
here's an application
that I built on PC that
allows me to do retraining.
But we're running inference
with TensorFlow Lite.
So it knows the scissors,
it knows the Post-It Notes,
but what if we got to a
really important object, one
that we haven't
seen before, perhaps
like something everybody has,
the a steel TensorFlow logo.
How is it going to do on that?
Well, not well is the
unfortunate thing.
But the good thing about machine
learning is we can fix it.
We just need some examples.
So here, this app allows
us to collect examples.
And you could imagine putting
this into a mobile app
where you just move
your phone around
and it captures a
bunch of examples.
I'm going to do the same
thing, except on Linux.
It's a little bit more
boring, but it does a job.
So we want to get
a lot of examples
to get a lot of generalization.
So once we're happy with that,
we'll hit the Train button
and that's going to do
some machine learning.
And once it's converged, we're
going to have a new model.
It's going to convert it
to TensorFlow Lite, which
is going to be really great.
We can test it out.
See if it's now detecting this.
And indeed it is.
That's good.
The other cool thing
about that is now
that we have this TF
Lite flat buffer model,
we can now run it on our
device and it works as well.
All right, great.
So, now that we've done pre
train models and we've done--
let's get into full on swimming.
There's basically four steps
that we need to work on.
The first one is
building and training
the model, which we've
already talked about.
You could do that with, again,
Swift would be a great way
to do that.
The second one is
converting the model.
Third one is
validating the model.
And the fourth is
deploying model.
Let's dive into them.
Well, we're not
going to dive yet.
We'll swim into them.
OK.
Build and train the model.
So the first thing to do is to
get a saved model of your model
and then use the converter.
This can be invoked in Python.
So you could have
your training script
and you could have
the last thing
you do is to just always
convert it to TensorFlow Lite.
I in fact recommend
that, because that
will allow you to
make sure that it's
convertible right
from the start.
So you give it the
saved model in,
and you provide the
TF Lite buffer out.
Great.
And then when you're done
with that, it will convert.
Except we don't
have all the ops.
So sometimes it won't.
So sometimes you want to
visualize the TensorFlow model.
So a lot of models do
work, but some of them
are going to have missing ops.
So as we've said, we've
listened to your feedback
and to address this we've
provided these visualizers
so you can understand
your models better.
They're kind of
analogous to TensorBoard.
In addition, we've also
added 75 built-in ops,
and we're announcing
a new feature,
which will allow us
to run TensorFlow
kernels in TensorFlow Lite.
So basically, this
will allow you
to run normal TensorFlow
kernels that we
don't have a built-in op for.
There is a trade to that,
because that increases
your binary size considerably.
However, it's a great
way to get started,
and it will kind of allow you to
get into using TensorFlow Lite
and deploy your model
if binary size is not
your primary constraint.
OK, great.
Once you have your model
working and converted,
you will definitely
want to validate it.
Every step of
machine learning it's
extremely important to
make sure it's still
running the way you think.
So if you have it working
in your Python test bench
and it's running, you need
to make sure it's also
running in your app.
This is just good practice,
that end-to-end things
are producing the right answer.
In addition, you might
want to do profiling
and you might want to
look at what your size is.
Once you've done that, you
want to convey this model
to the next phase,
which is optimization.
We're not going to
talk about that later,
but that's what you would
do with those results.
OK, so how do you deploy your
Model we have several APIs.
In the previous time
I talked about this,
we had c++ and Java.
Kind of in May or so we
introduced a Python API.
And I'm excited to talk
about our C API, which
is a way in which we're
going to implement
all of our different APIs,
similar to how TensorFlow does
it.
In addition, we're also
introducing an experimental C
Sharp API, which allows you
to use it in a lot of toolkits
that are C Sharp based.
The most notable of which--
which is a feature request--
was Unity.
So if you want to integrate
it into say a game.
OK, and then third, Objective
C to get a more idiomatic
traditional IOS experience.
Great.
Let me just give you an
example of some code here.
So the basic idea is
you give it the file
name of the flat buffer
model, you fill in the inputs,
and you call invoke.
Then you read out the outputs.
That's how all the APIs
has work, no matter
what language they are.
So this was Python.
The same is true in Java.
The same is true in c++.
Perhaps the C one is a
little bit more verbose,
but it should be
pretty intuitive.
OK, now that we
know how to swim,
let's go into
diving into models.
How do we optimize a model?
So once you have
your model working,
you might want to get the
best performance possible,
and you might want to
leverage custom hardware.
This traditionally implies
modifying the model.
So the way in which we're
going to do this is we're
going to put this into
our [INAUDIBLE] loop.
We had our four steps
before as part of swimming,
but now we have the
additional diving model
where we do optimization.
And how does optimization work?
We're introducing this thing
called the model optimization
toolkit, and the
cool thing about it
is it allows you to optimize
your model either post
training or during training.
So that means that you
can do a lot of things
without retraining the
model, but to get the--
let me just give an
example, which is right now
we're doing quantization.
So there's two ways
to do quantization.
One is, you take your model
and look at what ranges it uses
and then just say we're going
to quantize this model right now
by just setting those ranges.
So that's called post
training quantization.
So all you need to do that is
add a flag to the conversion.
I showed you the Python
converter before.
There's also a command line one.
But both of them have this
option to quantize the weights.
In addition, if you want to do
a training time quantization,
we introduced the tool
kit for doing this.
This is now kind of put under
the model optimization toolkit,
and this will basically create
you a new training graph
that when you run
it, it will give you
the most optimal training
quantized graph that you could.
It kind of takes advantage--
it takes into account that it
is going to be quantized.
So basically, the loss function
is aware of the quantization.
So that's good.
OK.
So, just one more thing
that I want to talk about,
which is roadmap.
We're looking actively into
things like on-device training,
which will, of course, require
us to investigate control flow.
We're adding more techniques
to the optimization toolkit.
We'd also like to provide more
hardware acceleration support.
And the last thing is
for TensorFlow 2.0,
we're moving out of contrib
and into TensorFlow.
So we'll be under
TensorFlow slash Lite.
OK, so a couple demos.
I wanted to show a couple
of models that were using--
so TensorFlow Lite.
So for example,
here's one model that
allows you to see the gaze.
So it's running in real time.
It basically puts
boxes around people
and kind of gives a
vector of which direction
they're looking.
And this is running in real
time on top of TensorFlow
Lite on an Edge TPU.
Let me show you another one.
Oh, sorry.
OK.
It's very tricky.
There we go.
Here's another one that's
kind of interesting.
Again, this is using
a variant of SSD.
It's basically three
autonomous agents,
or two autonomous agents
and one human driven agent.
Two of the agents are trying
to catch the other one
and the other one's
trying to avoid.
And they're all
input in this SSD.
Basically, the upshot of this
is that it uses SSD that's
accelerated with Edge TPUs.
It's about 40% faster using
to Edge TPUs and TF Lite.
And I have one more demo,
which is an app that's
using TF Lite called Yummly.
And basically, this
is able to give you
recipes based on what it sees.
So let's just see it in action.
So this was originally
built on TF Mobile,
but then moved to TF Lite.
So, this is their demo.
So essentially, you point your
phone at what's in your fridge
and it will tell you
what to make with it.
This is good for
me, because I don't
have any creativity
on cooking and I have
a lot of random ingredients.
So we're really excited by what
people are using TF Lite for.
I want to show
you one more demo,
which I just made last week
with some of my colleagues.
And it's basically running
on a microcontroller.
So this is basically
a microcontroller
with a touch screen
that has only one
megabyte of flash memory
and 340 kilobytes of RAM.
So this is sort of
pretty small, and we're
doing speech recognition on it.
So I say, yes.
And it says, yes.
It says no.
And if I say some random
thing, it says unknown
So pre-recorded.
Unfortunately, I don't
have the sound on yet.
But this is just showing that
we can run the same interpreter
code on these really
small devices.
So we can go all the way to IoT,
which I think is super exciting
and will introduce a whole
new set of applications
that are possible.
So with that, I already
told you this, which
we're moving out of contrib.
I'd like you guys to
try out TensorFlow.
Send us some information.
If you're interested
in discussing it,
go on to our mailing list,
tflite@tensorflow.org.
And we're really excited
to hear about new use cases
and to hear feedback.
So thank you.
We're going to-- both of us
are going to be at the booth
over in the grand ballroom.
So if you want to talk to
us more about either Swift
or TensorFlow Lite, that would
be a great time to do it.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]